how does season two of the hills new
beginnings compare to season
one obviously you're all living under
the same roof this time around
i'm new that's a good name there's
somebody missing and now there's
somebody here
um that has never been here before so
that's one way
i also think that um because we're in
our second season we've all spent
a considerable amount of time together
and
developing both problems and better
relationships amongst the group so i
think there's just a lot more
really in-depth and and like genuine
both conflict and really kind of
touching
things that happen throughout the season
so in that sense i feel like there's a
lot more depth
probably into this season yeah the
piggyback off that i definitely think
this season
is much more deep raw and real than last
season especially for everything going
on the pandemic us coming together
like it was a very vulnerable time for
all of us to be together
and we experienced a lot of that rawness
as
a group and kind of more of a family
this season than last season
everybody had something that they were
going through caroline and you did
mention you are new so welcome to the
cast thank you
thank you so much i am curious because i
actually spoke to misha barton not too
long ago
and she sounded like she would be back
obviously she's not
so what's your side of the story there
it's
really a long side so we might have to
chat another time
however i thought we were friends and
then i found out through coming on
here and there last season i found out
through people that i won't name
that we actually were not friends um
unbeknownst to me
and then they just called me and they
said we
listened to kind of your microphone and
you hanging out last season and we think
you're rad
and we would love you to come on and i
didn't know i was
directly replacing her and when she
heard that she went crazy and started
talking about it and she posted on her
instagram actually a really nice picture
of me so thank you misha
um but there was this whole picture of
me saying like get your story straight
nobody would want to watch caroline de
moray hawk her greasy pasta bowls
it's like watching paint dry i have it
memorized because i saw it so many times
and i just thought it was just so cruel
and so mean to just kind of go out there
and
talk about somebody for no reason and
then
i ended up actually she didn't have her
story straight so
i guess it was like on her face like she
said well thank you for sharing your
side of the story and we're glad to have
you i'm sure you're going to add a lot
of
flair caroline is
very well that was in here
tell us how it is for sure definitely